foreign
[Music]
we spent those you know two seasons or
whatever you know I mean and and like
we're buddies we're we're close like we
were we were friends I think like there
was one time I remember what year it was
like we went out in New York and me and
you kind of like we're like oh you like
you're like for real and then like I
remember like Stephen had some trouble
with the bouncer and I went like dealt
with this guy like you you and me and
and Scott like out on the road man yeah
and we we had some like magical [ __ ]
times oh yeah like magical [ __ ] times
and like I don't know man for me like
Scott Scott is like he is like
legitimately a hero like he's like I
love Scott yeah like talk talk about him
a little bit Scott Wilson
first time first time I really did a
scene with Scott what Scott used to
sneak into my trailer all the time and
he have a little flask and he'd be like
shut the door you know I'm like get in
here but he and I became really really
good friends I I just loved Scott you
know I I think because I didn't know my
dad as much as I would have liked to
when I find guys that I really respect
of that age
I I [ __ ] I stick to them I did it
with Kris Kristofferson like I just I
stick to them and I'm like I don't know
what it is and I just I just love them
and Scott was so open he was so honest
um last time I saw Scott was uh
was at his house throughout his house
and we were watching his uh In Cold
Blood audition and he's sitting there
next to me and he he can't speak very
well and we're sitting there watching
the room's totally quiet
and I looked over at him and he looked
over at me and I go you're such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he just starts
laughing you know
and I I regretted not being able able to
come to his funeral and it was he died
right on the same day my daughter was
born
and I couldn't go because we were in
labor
dude that's [ __ ] heavy I couldn't
remember that now
crazy right
wow and that's why I wasn't there
wow
yeah man uh
I have so many so many Scott Wilsons
yeah I mean and and and by the way man
like that dude could like I mean you and
me were like getting after it oh yeah
and oh yeah that dude [ __ ] I mean we
crushed us we crushed it was like a
[ __ ] like hot joke it would be like
four in the morning you and me would be
like stumble I mean just so disgusting
and shameful how we were but we would be
like stumbling back and Scott would just
be like yeah I'm gonna go back you know
let me go get uh yeah I'm gonna clam
chowder down the street
totally fine yeah yeah he's the best and
and I know like when Sarah was up did
you did you see that uh you know I had
Sarah on this I did yeah and like like
uh you know I know we like when she and
I talked we talked a little bit about
Frank and all that stuff yeah like
what's your what what's your thing on
Frank like I didn't know Frank as well
as you guys knew Frank yeah I kind of
came on it was only six episodes right I
came on a number three you know and
Frank didn't have the conversations with
he was like in love with you and Andy
and Sarah you guys were the group
um
so I didn't know him as well as you knew
him I just got I just met him you know
and then
you know you guys went to Comic-Con I
believe and it was announced while he
was a Comic-Con some crazy shady [ __ ]
like that I was bombed yeah and I
remember you know I remember working
with him
and he was so in it like I remember that
at one point they were like you need you
know crawling under a car and I jump up
behind D dog and all this stuff happens
and
and the makeup artist he was like Norman
needs more dirt
and she's like no no that matches and he
goes ugh
he picks up grease off the ground and
just wipes it across my face and I was
like oh my God I love you so much you
know and you remember back then
especially all I wanted to be was filthy
all I was so dirty I would steal the
dirt take it back to my room and apply
more to it when they weren't looking
like and they'd be like you're so filthy
I was like I want them to smell me into
the television that's great
um I just loved it yeah I'm a I'm a dude
yes
um
Frank to work with he was he was so
inspirational and and it's true what
Sarah said about the scripts we got six
scripts right off the bat yeah yeah less
than a year before the show I was like
in jail I was like that show like saved
my life so so for me I was like the fact
that you gave me the shot was so like
I'd never had a big gig for me so I was
like but you you just got your [ __ ]
star on the Hollywood [ __ ] Walk of
Fame man you know in the last second you
know like I I was gonna make the speech
for you you know what I mean which was
like [ __ ] crazy and I called Sarah
like then if I called everybody but I
called Sarah and and I was like man like
like what what should I say about Norman
and she was like do you know what you
said to me like
at the end of season one about Norman I
was like what you were like I think he's
allergic to acting he's allergic to
[ __ ] he's allergic to pretension
because I used to say this thing about
you where like your acting style was
just like burst of authentic like I
would be there like trying to like like
kill somebody and then I would like look
over and see the way that you were doing
it and it was like it was just like so
[ __ ] real you know and it was like
these bursts of just like absolute
inarguable authentic moments right like
are you aware of that do you feel like
that
no I I mean I
I guess there's certain things I don't
give a [ __ ] about uh
you know I I maybe I got beat up too
much as a kid and I don't know I you
know my first job right I was working at
I was working at a motorcycle place in
Venice right
called Dr Carl's hog Hospital right
I got fired from that job somehow ended
up in a play the play turned into a
movie
and I didn't know what I was doing on
the first movie and my dad was dying
right and there was a scene in the movie
where
you know he comes out in a wheelchair
and he kind of stands up well China
gives me a hug and it's this big
emotional moment and the director is
like how do you want to prepare for this
and I go like what are my options like
what do you do you know I had no idea
what I was doing
we we talked for saying he gives me a
phone I call my dad he can barely talk
on the phone I hang up the phone they
come get me and I just cried so much
that one of the crew members said you
know at lunch we're in Maine right and
everyone ate in a 10 he said he goes you
know I didn't go to lunch I went took a
little nap in my little room and he said
nobody's nobody spoke like that's how
good that scene was everyone would just
sat there and quiet
and I was like oh
that's what this is so I I didn't learn
to act you know I kind of
learned as I got jobs
I think if it would have been the other
way if I'd gone to acting school or
something like that
I think it would be different I think
every my I mean I feel like everything
sort of works the way it's supposed to
work but but like there's something
about intentionality right like there's
something about like if you go to acting
school it's like hey I really want to do
this and a lot of people go to acting
school right they want to like be a star
they want to be an actor they want to go
be in on stage like you didn't like I'm
still not sure I do right yeah so like
tell me about that I like doing other
things too you know and
I think if I think of it
if I had to do
a lot of the stuff I feel like you're
told you have to do especially in places
like this uh
I don't think it would hold my interest
you know I think uh I'm very aware of
time I'm very aware of mortality I'm
very aware of wasting energy on things
and I I don't want to waste any time
which is probably why I do so much [ __ ]
you know
um I want to learn stuff I want to make
real connections the star is awesome I
can't believe I had a star and all it
was [ __ ] insane uh but will you know
will I talk about it again probably not
unless somebody brings it up
um the acting thing I'm still learning
about it which is I think what's holding
my interest you know uh
there's something about being on this TV
show this long where people see me age
in real time that I find kind of
interesting I'm always looking for those
friendships like we had starting that
show I'm always chasing that you know
um
but I don't you know I don't know it's
not that I don't give a [ __ ] because I
do give a [ __ ] but there's a lot of
things I think that I don't give a [ __ ]
about as well I remember being in I
think it was Junior High and I'm at
another new school and I'm walking home
down an alley and there's this group on
the side and there's this group on the
side and there's a bunch of guys and a
bunch of guys and I'm walking down the
middle
and it's some annual fight they have
and walk in and they go upstairs which
fight which side are you fighting on and
I went [ __ ] you both and I walked down
and they all beat me up and they got
along great after that it was you know
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you and I think I
still kind of have that attitude 100 you
know what I mean so like where do you
think that sense of like uh mortality
and and time like where do you think
that comes from I think it comes from my
dad dying my mom used to sell uh
coffins
right she called them Eternal beds I
went to a lot of a lot of funerals
um
yeah you know I don't I just I'm just
aware of it I'm aware of like you know
time goes really quick
I don't I don't really [ __ ] very
much you know I'm not good at small talk
I don't like to go out at night and put
myself in a situation and you know when
I used to like when you and I would go
out I was first one that was obliter
like obliterated and that's the only way
that I could have small talk with people
is I just get trashed but then you know
once it started working once I had a
little girl I just kind of stopped it
all
[Music]
all right
foreign